meine maus park wieder mal minecraft cvp
junge habe ich das schon gedacht dass
ich da da konnte man nicht viel machen
wie viel leben hattest du denn ich hatte
ich hatte folgt glaube ich steht dann
hätte hätte zwei kämpfen müssen ja ich
würde auf jeden fall nachher für die
aktion noch richtig den arsch treten
leute sorry aber egal immerhin hamburg
ist besser als ghana aber ich muss aber
ganz ehrlich sagen
keine ahnung auf 1 gg und so aber wir
hätten einfach nicht machen können so
wir haben uns verfolgt und ich konnte
mir kommt noch nicht mehr lang sprinten
sowas ja die waren wahrscheinlich voll
über essen
das problem scheiße ärgerlich man und
die hat noch finde ich nicht so ein
geiles braun ok wat ich habe ich ihn
weiter tormann ich werde mich nachher
richtig drüber aufregen leute jetzt hab
ich noch gar nicht realisiert
ich auch nicht jetzt habe ich wenigstens
kein stress von urlaub vor zu
produzieren ich hoffe jetzt einfach dass
max überlebt hat ja ich auch ich hoffe
dass so max überlegt hat max und justine
hofft dass penn gestorben nein wenn
darüber leben müssten aber das team hat
uns gefehlt hat auch logik gilt also ja
ja ja dieses verhalten to be one
situation dass hacker ja ja und das
wasser das war ja ja und ich konnte auch
nicht mehr lange ich konnte nicht mehr
sprinten weiß dass ich meinen es hat ist
eine glückssache ist eine glückssache
wenn ihr sind ja hinter einem oder nicht
kann nix mal egal was jetzt noch
überlegen ob ich dir das fleisch trocken
soll aber das hatte auch nicht mehr
gereicht aber gut ja ich heiße für eine
wenig man warte war unser ziel weil ich
die erste folge zu überleben noch nicht
richtig ich auch nicht ich auch nicht
ich bin noch zu sehr unter schock aber
es sind viele leute gestorben
ziemlich viele ja wie immer das normal
passt also der pid würde mich nachher
richtig aufregen leute beleidigen
jetzt packt ihr so den spuren alter kann
ich ja überhaupt noch was
also ich habe mein schwert tg sich für
mich nein
das hätte ich bin ein mann der so schön
gewesen erste folge schon ein paar kills
und soja ohne witz dann kam ein
effektives zocken alter ich spiele zwei
wallerstädten eigentlich wird richtig
rein steckt ohne bitrate 313 kills
direkt ins sind warum geht man keine
changes gekriegt wir dachten schon noch
sehr wenig in die mitte alles 11
es war auch alles gut aber ich wusste
nicht wissen als die so direkt bei uns
sind alt womit die wo sind die denken
ich überhaupt bei uns gesprochen die
sind einfach ende mit den weiteren
gelaufen weil hier ja hier mache die
ordentlich geld schon länger man leider
ist so scheidet 5g ist alles gleich
jetzt alle kids nacht ich dann bei drei
kids alter er war immer ein hobby kids
gemacht werden das musste mal so aber
schade aber war klar dass so viele
sterben aber ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass wir so direkt sterben sechs da man
hat vermutet so weiß dass ich mein aber
gar nichts vermutet alter nehme ich
meine da ich hab ich schon irgendwie
angst ich hatte schon so eine bestimmte
stelle deutlich meine attacke bekommen
oder der gangster hier nee ich hab jetzt
auf den safe gar nichts gerade leute der
im baum hat auch noch unnötig oder
unpassend john jairo visto wo bist du
eigentlich
ich glaube gerade klein klein rot tritt
beim biathlon leistet für mich denn
schon mal kriegst du deine kritik an
george ist gar nichts gemacht
wie sieht der mensch aus ihm gemacht
nicht schlecht auch mancher auch
community geschlagen einen springer ins
wasser weg so oder so wir haben hier in
bogen vielleicht alles um bogen dir
keinen bogen
egal wie egal sie im käse ist glaube ich
gerade läuft auf jeden fall finde ich
mich jetzt eine gewisse person wäre
würde ich aber schreiben sieben teams in
der ersten folge mache ich aber
natürlich nicht aber regel patron das
ist jetzt die frage leute welche
personen könnte so ein titel schreiben
ein tipp sie sind war schon raus also
wer oder was nicht hier
junge fünf kinder was ist los ob oder
was wir können aber die halbe runde
zusammen locker otto dix krippe bitte
ich bin da einfach ein bisschen toleranz
junge ohne witz ist so ich hab grad so
dann hat er erstmal seinen namen als
camper gratiskindergarten und es stimmt
ja die ganze drum kämpfen will und seine
clips entscheiden will
dann haute ab dann haut er ab auch im
malen leute rakim oder ohne witz jetzt
nicht persönlich das schon ein bisschen
mit mir oder bist du was geht was kinder
kommen sich von trecker weg nicht noch
so scheiße schlimm
mal gucken was diese und unnütze
gestalten als nächstes machen wird
wieder angeln immer gespannt wer noch so
gestorben ist aber ich bin ich also wie
sie sind auch die folge lief vor allem
gerade erst 34 minuten oder so haben
kids geholt läuft man übrigens noch mal
ein chaos und ein choleriker dass die
story mannes an die verdient war war
aber auch solidarisch von mir dass ich
den kerl gelassen haben holen können
weiß aber ich habe den anderen auch so
sehen welches so gold dekorierte hab ich
ja außerdem auch noch geld du hast ja ja
ja ja ich habe weiter geht gilt aber du
hast ich hab halt abgestaubt du wirst du
hast ja aber du hast vorgelesen erwarte
ich schaue mal ist der jetta auch noch
da tatsächlich dass beide kits geholt da
bin ich mal den killeen war oh ja hallo
ich habe einfach mit aufgeschlagen bevor
etwas passiert jungen eis nicht hast
schon recht okay aber es hat uns nichts
gebracht naja immerhin haben wir
praktisch
vielleicht bleibe ich an dem dahin
einfach mal dran dass er sich keine
kunden holen kann dass wir den pm beg
verleihen können du kannst ja nochmal
einen hohlen einkommens tm1 der summe so
wenn ich einen finden würde
ob ihn ein unnötiger projekt wirklich
schön mit angel und alles mögliche
spielen leute ist mir scheißegal unit
sein kann als mensch dann lauf doch
wenigstens das ist glaube ich einfach
das einfach auf aids ausgelegt mit
seiner spieltaktik glaube ich ganz
ehrlich wir müssen darauf achten dass
der auf gar keinen fall die runde
gewerke die mitte ärgerlich war die
ganze vorbereitung vor allen dingen und
dann aber man ist in dem moment einfach
nicht konzentriert das ist wie ein film
das ist wirklich ein filmleute man
schaut was sich selbst eigentlich zu in
dem moment ja ärgerlich haben hat ja
gesehen wie schnell man denkt bei dem
auch noch bitte haben noch in köln ist
auf jeden fall im finale den typen weg
mal an wie viele kids jetzt schon haben
also noch mal sorry leute aber wir
hatten da nichts machen
vor den tests ohne weil sich das ist ein
richtiger eingefädelt richtige
missgeburt 38 kills alter was ist los in
dieser runde läuft bei dir
wenn ich dich jetzt noch kindern hab ich
auch angst versetzte kills erste folge
gilt oder haben habe ich geschrieben von
verdient egal
lasst uns alle server in bogen
vielleicht von meisterfeier hast du mir
ein bisschen mehr
drei zwei eins meins war eigentlich vor
die kunden chancen gehabt man egal
immerhin bin ich als team gestorben und
nicht an den ball
chilipoker schiller meine maus park
wieder mal minecraft der op
wir haben einfach die komplette runde
gewonnen da ist mir aufgefallen ja was
ihm gefallen
doch einfach kommt ähnlich sind wie viel
freier oder noch bisschen mehr
30 stück hat mit 30 29 verschwinden vor
allem aber ich will die ganze holen das
bringt trägt eben nicht bereit das geld
p 3000 leute durch fall würde ich sagen
ja
ja was soll da noch zu sagen also dinge
geht jetzt auch perfekt 15 minuten also
könne eigentlich tschüss sagen
vielleicht noch der ausblick auf die
nächste folge warum klappt okay ich
musste das marschieren
leute wir sehen uns bei der nächsten
folge wieder mehr culpa oder nuestra
culpa tut uns leid aber rein nehmen sich
so schwer hat rein macht's gut und